es ist ein fragwürdiges satire video des
öffentlich rechtlichen senders funk und
es sorgt jetzt für viel aufregung
es beschäftigt sich mit dem thema des
racial profiling bei der polizei hier in
deutschland und im internet wird es
jetzt heftig diskutiert so heißt es
unter anderem dass es
gebührenfinanzierter hass auf polizisten
schämt euch für solche pauschalvorwürfe
vom cdu bundestagsabgeordneten matthias
hauer
aber ein generalverdacht soll es eben
nicht sein schreibt comedian und
hauptdarsteller aurel märz aber machen
sich selber ein bild
walter hatte mal da stimmt was nicht
das ist ja klar das sieht man doch hier
richard gere 12 wir brauchen dringend
verstärkungen ein ausländer macht sich
ecke weserstraße an einem fahrrad zu
schaffen
ende die minister aber so wie der
aussieht könnte er auch ein deutscher
sein
quatsch ich weiß ja wohl wien aus hinaus
sieht das sehe ich ein bisschen helfen
schwarzen ich kann ihnen nicht einordnen
das auf jeden fall zur hälfte einen
drogendealer aber für ein fahrrad da der
radler schwarz genug
ich habe aber auch schon mal von albinos
schwarzen gehört die sind ganz frei ist
aber wenn er weiß ist ist er dann immer
noch ein ausländer ihr wisst dass ich
euch verstehen an 412 im brabus in
position
gottseidank nehmen sie den verdächtigen
ins visier er es schwarz gelb schwarz
dazu sagt man jetzt bei koch das ist ein
riesenthema
das wirst du noch jungs oder
deswegen habe ich noch ein hubschrauber
hinzugezogen
hey wenn jetzt denke ich mir das ist
mein fahrrad ist auch ein fahrradpass
aber wenn er jetzt nämlich steht
[Musik]
kostete er
jetzt hat das war notwehr hätte er sonst
was in seiner tasche haben können
scheiße fahrradpass der kasse lesen
scharfe kanten staatsbürgerschaft
deutsch also wirklich so kommt da
ursprünglich her
das ist doch die frage was denn wie
sagte doch einer von uns und über dieses
umstrittene video möchte ich jetzt
sprechen mit bild chefreporter frank
schneider mir nun zugeschaltet frank hat
die polizei bereits auf diesen clip
reagiert ja ich habe viele polizisten
darüber gesprochen und es ist eine
mischung aus gut ärger auch wirklich
total verständnislosigkeit
fassungslosigkeit weil sie sagen suchen
wir da die familie werden wir werden
nicht nur als total dumm dargestellt
wird auch so dargestellt dass polizisten
nur danach gucken welche hautfarbe ein
und dann ist es erst mal relativ egal
was er macht er wird sofort von uns als
täter wahrgenommen und wird dann auch
sofort erschossen wenn er sich nur
falsch bewegt und das hat die polizei
das ist natürlich so eine diffamierung
und so ein generalverdacht und da dieses
racial profiling ist ja immer schon ein
reiz begriff gewesen und teilweise über
die normale polizei war damit bekommt
dann muss man da ganz kleine prinz ihren
das ist bresche profiling aber wie
gesagt das entsetzen bei der polizei
über diesen clip ist groß man muss sich
überlegen werken erst vor geraumer zeit
diesen artikel in der taz
polizisten würden alle auf den müll und
irgendwann ist bei den polizisten jetzt
auch mal der punkt erreicht
sie sagen wir werden jeden tag ablehnung
und hass ausgesetzt auf der straße die
leute immer aggressiver uns gegenüber es
gibt immer mehr übergriffe und
widerstände und jetzt sehen wir auch
noch in den medien so diffamiert als
dumme rassistische und mörderische
beamte
und ja da ist der schock sitzt da
wirklich tief das haben wir auch gerade
schon einige clips gesehen während du
gesprochen hast das waren dann echte
jetzt in frankfurt düsseldorf und
hamburg kam es die letzten tage zu
videoaufnahmen die immer wieder gezeigt
haben wie hart die polizei doch
durchgegriffen hat wie ist als jetzt die
reaktion darauf gibt es da schon erste
erkenntnisse von diesen vorfällen und
hat man das gefühl dass das vielleicht
auch daran liegt dass jetzt eben solche
satire clips oder clips die als satire
bezeichnet werden entstehen überhaupt ja
man muss sagen die satire gibt er ist ja
schon ein paar wochen alt er ist ja
nicht entstanden durch diese vorfeld
jetzt in düsseldorf frankfurt und
hamburg und auch da muss man wieder klar
differenzieren erstens muss man immer
sagen diese clips beginnt natürlich
immer erst an der stelle wo die polizei
aktiv wird wenn wir jetzt gar den
düsseldorfer clip sehen da muss man
sagen dieser jugendliche 15 jahre alt
ist seit er 13 ist polizeibekannt es
gibt vorwürfe wegen gefährlicher
körperverletzung bedrohung nötigung
diebstahl
das heißt er ist total polizei bekannt
und man muss wissen er hat völlig
unmotiviert die polizeiwachen
angegriffen
sie gingen gegen eine gruppe von zehn
randalierern vor zu denen er eigentlich
gar nicht gehörte er hat sich dann ein
gemisch polizisten angegriffen wurde
daraufhin zu boden gebracht
man muss immer aufpassen dass man täter
und opfer da nicht auch immer irgendwie
ja vermischt denn er hat wird sein die
ursache auch für die festnahme gesetzt
trotzdem ist natürlich total richtig
dass die polizei sich vernünftig und
eben auch vorschrift von raum verhält
und in düsseldorf wird das gerade
geprüft dass es noch sehr strittig bei
der sache in frankfurt muss man deutlich
sagen da tritt ein polizeibeamter in den
tatverdächtigen hinein
es geht gar nicht man sieht auch sofort
auf dem video wie ein polizist ihn
wegschiebt dieser vorfall ist auch
polizeiintern noch vor veröffentlichung
dieses videos gemeldet worden
das heißt auch die anderen kollegen
haben die nicht geschützt sondern sind
sofort zum vorgesetzten gegangen und
haben diesen vorfall gemeldet dort wird
auch ermittelt intern und das wird
vermutlich auch noch befördert
gefährliche körperverletzung im amt
hinauslaufen und dann muss man auch
wieder in den saal sehen in hamburg auch
david ja große da sei nur einer zu
schnell mit sagen ist gut gefahren
auch da sagt der polizei das stimmt so
nicht das war zwar die ursache er sollte
gestoppt werden wegen einer
ordnungswidrigkeit und dann hat er
daraufhin die polizisten wollte sich
nicht ausweisen als sie dann
dann auch was aber sehen wollten und
ihnen festhalten wollten hat er um sich
geschlagen und daraufhin ist auch so
viel verstärkung gerufen worden und dann
wollte man ihn zu boden bringen weil er
sich weiterhin geweigert hat seinen
ausweis zu zeigen
und da beginnt natürlich das video ist
das heißt also die vorgeschichte sieht
man immer nicht gut man sieht alle drei
fälle sind völlig unterschiedlich
gelagert aber vielleicht noch mal einen
satz zum thema racial profiling
innenminister hat man so schön gesagt ja
wenn die drogendealer am hauptbahnhof
hauptsächlich farbige sind es ist ja
unsinnig dass polizeibeamte anfangen die
die oma zu kontrollieren mit ihrer
handtasche dort herläuft dh man muss
eben auch sagen dass häufig eben taten
verübt werden wie auch in den fällen
immer des widerstandes relativ häufig um
überproportional von jungen männern mit
migrantischem hintergrund und die gehen
dann meistens auch polizisten sehr
aggressiv los und deswegen sehe ich das
natürlich eine öffentlichkeit manchmal
das gefühl naja die gehen immer nur
bestimmte klientel vor warum muss ich
noch mal infrage stellen
wir haben es ja auch wir sehen in
stuttgart bei den ausschreitungen geht
vielleicht auch diese gruppe gegen
polizei anders vor was ist da die
ursache was es die wirkung und mit so
einem diffamierenden und baustoffe
umgerissenen video hilft sicherlich der
öffentlich rechtliche rundfunk den
polizisten und auch der gesellschaft
nicht weiter